so when you start talking about this  person ain't gonna do this you know  maybe i didn't do that but you you're  being selfish and anytime you're being  selfish it's never going to be it's  never going to produce abundance  it's never gonna you're never gonna be  blessed so when people ask me why i do  what i do i don't lead you in the wrong  way because i understand that if i do  that i can get some quick money but i'm  not into quick money i want to build a  long relationship i want to build a  solid foundation i want us to be so the  first thing you have to do is you have  to work on your character because what  happens when you become no disrespect  but you look at these guys who are  making millions of dollars playing  sports but then you hear the stuff  that's going on in a personal life  that's because you had a lot of talent  but no character to go with the talents